the problem is that we do not get 50
years to try and try again and observe
that we were wrong and come up with a
different Theory and realize that the
entire thing is going to be like way
more difficult and realized at the start
because the first time you fail at
aligning something much smarter than you
are you die and you do not get to try
again
and if we if every time we built a
poorly aligned superintelligence and it
killed us all we got to observe how it
had killed us and you know not
immediately know why but like come up
with theories and come up with the
theory of how you do it differently and
try it again and build another Super
intelligence then have that kill
everyone and then like oh well I guess
that didn't work either and try again
and become grizzled cynics and tell the
young guide research researchers that
it's not that easy then in 20 years or
50 years I think we would eventually
crack it in other words I do not think
that alignment is fundamentally harder
than artificial intelligence was in the
first place
but if we needed to get artificial
intelligence correct on the first try or
die we would all definitely now be dead
that is a more difficult more lethal
form of the problem like if those people
in 1956 had needed to correctly guess
how hard AI was and like correctly
theorize how to do it on the first try
or everybody dies and nobody gets to do
any more signs and everybody would be
dead and we wouldn't get to do any more
signs that's the difficulty you've
you've talked about this that we have to
get alignment right on the first quote
critical try why is that the case what
is this critical how do you think about
the critical trial and why do I have to
get it right
it is something sufficiently smarter
than you that everyone will die if it's
not a lot I mean there's
you can like sort of zoom in closer and
be like well the actual critical moment
is the moment when it can deceive you
when it can
talk its way out of the box when it can
bypass your security measures and get
onto the internet noting that all these
things are presently being trained on
computers that are just like on the
internet which is you know like not a
very smart life decision for for us as a
species
Because the Internet contains
information about how to escape because
if you're like on a giant server
connected to the internet and that is
where your AI systems are being trained
then if they are
if you get to the level of AI technology
where they're aware that they are there
and they can decompile code and they can
like
find security flaws in the system
running them then they will just like be
on the internet there's not an air gap
on the present methodology so if they
can manipulate whoever is controlling it
into letting it escaped onto the
internet and then exploit hacks if they
can manipulate The Operators or
disjunction
find security holes in the system
running them
so manipulating operators is the um the
human engineering right that's also
holes so all of it is manipulation
either the code or the human code the
human mind or the the human change I
agree that the like macro security
system has human holes and machine holes
and then they could just exploit any
hole
yep
so it could be that like the critical
moment is not when is it smart enough
that everybody's about to fall over dead
but rather like when is it smart enough
that it can get onto
a
less controlled GPU cluster with it
faking the books on what's actually
running on that GPU cluster and start
improving itself without humans watching
it and then it gets smart enough to kill
everyone from there but it wasn't smart
enough to kill everyone at the critical
moment when you like
screwed up
when you needed to have done better by
that point where everybody dies I think
implicit but maybe explicit
idea in your discussion of this point is
that we can't learn much about the
alignment problem before this critical
try
is that is that is that what you believe
do you think and if so why do you think
that's true we can't do research on
alignment
before we reach this critical point
so the problem is is that what you can
learn on the weak systems may not
generalize to the very strong systems
because these strong systems are going
to be important in different and are
going to be different in important ways
um Chris ola's team has been working on
inter mechanistic interpretability
understanding what is going on inside
the giant inscrutable matrices of
floating Point numbers by taking a
telescope to them and figuring out what
is going on in there have they made
progress
yes
have they made enough progress
well
you can try to quantify this in
different ways one of the ways I've
tried to quantify It Is by putting up a
prediction Market on whether in 2026
we will have understood anything that
goes on inside a
Giant
Transformer net that
was not known to us in 2006.
like we have now understood induction
heads in these systems by didn't of much
research and great sweat and Triumph
which is like if you like a thing where
if you go like a b a b a b it'll be like
oh I bet that continues a b
um
and a bit more complicated than that but
the point is like
we knew about regular expressions in
2006 and these are like pretty simple as
regular Expressions go
so this is a case where like by dint of
great sweat we understood what is going
on inside a Transformer but it's not
like the thing that makes Transformers
smart it's a kind of thing that we could
have done by built by hand
decades earlier
your intuition that
the strong AGI versus weak AGI type
systems
could be fundamentally different
can you can you unpack that intuition a
little bit Yeah I think there's multiple
thresholds
um an example is the point at which
a system has sufficient intelligence and
situational awareness and understanding
of human psychology that it would have
the capability to desire to do so to
fake being aligned like it knows what
responses demons are looking for and can
compute the responses looking humans are
looking for and give those responses
without it necessarily being the case
that it is sincere about that you know
the it's a very understandable way for
an intelligent being to act humans do it
all the time imagine if your plan for
um
you know achieving a good government is
you're going to ask anyone who requests
to be dictator of the country
um
if they're a good person
and if they say no you don't let them be
dictator
now the reason this doesn't work is that
people can be smart enough to realize
that the answer you're looking for is
yes I'm a good person and say that even
if they're not really good people
so
the work of alignment might be
qualitatively different
above that threshold of intelligence or
beneath it it doesn't it doesn't have to
be like a very sharp threshold but you
know like
there's the there's the point where
you're like Building A system that is
not in some sense know you're out there
and it's not in some sense smart enough
to fake anything
and there's a point where the system is
definitely that smart and there are
weird in-between cases like
gpt4 which you know like we have no
insight into what's going on in there
and so we don't know to what extent
there's like a thing that in some sense
has learned what responses the
reinforcement learning by human feedback
is trying to entrain and is like
calculating how to give that versus like
aspects of it that naturally talk that
way have been reinforced yeah I I wonder
if there could be measures of how
manipulative a thing is so I think of
Prince Michigan character from uh The
Idiot by
uh Dostoevsky is this kind of a
perfectly purely naive character
I I wonder if there's a spectrum between
zero manipulation
transparent naive almost to the point of
naiveness to
sort of deeply Psychopathic manipulative
and I wonder if it's possible I would
avoid the term Psychopathic like humans
can be Psychopaths and AI that was never
you know like never had that stuff in
the first place it's not like a
defective human it's its own thing but
leaving that aside well as a small aside
I wonder if what part of psychology
which has its flaws as a discipline
already could be mapped or expanded to
include AI systems that sounds like a
dreadful mistake just like start over
with AI systems if they're imitating
humans who have known psychiatric
disorders then sure you may be able to
predict
it like if you then sure like if you ask
it to behave in a psychotic fashion and
it obligingly does so then you may be
able to predict its responses by using
the theory of psychosis but if you're
just yeah like no like start over with
yeah don't drag the psychology I I just
disagree with that I mean it's a it's a
beautiful idea to start over but I don't
I think fundamentally the system is
trained on human data on language from
the internet and it's currently aligned
with uh rlhf uh reinforcement learning
with human feedback
so humans are constantly in the loop of
the training procedure so it feels like
in some fundamental way
it is training what it means to to think
and speak like a human so that there
must be aspects of psychology that
they're mappable just like you said with
Consciousness it's part of the text so I
I mean there's the question of to what
extent it is thereby being made more
human-like versus to what extent an
alien actress is learning to play human
characters
I thought that's what I'm constantly
trying to do when I interact with other
humans is trying to fit in trying to
play the a a robot trying to play human
characters
so I don't know how much of human
interaction is trying to play a
character versus being Who You Are
I don't I don't really know what it
means to be a social human I do think
that the that
those people who go through their whole
lives wearing masks and never take it
off because they don't know the internal
mental motion for taking it off
or think that the mask that they wear
just is themselves
I think those people are closer to the
masks that they wear than an alien from
another planet would
like learning how to predict the next
word that every kind of human on the
internet says
mask is an interesting word
but if you're always wearing a mask
in public and in private
aren't you the mask
like I mean I I think that you are more
than the mask I think the mask is a
slice through you it may even be the
slice that's in charge of you yeah but
if your self-image is of somebody who
never
gets angry or something
and yet your voice starts to tremble
under certain circumstances there's a
thing that's inside you that the mask
says isn't there
and that like even the mask you wear
internally is like telling inside your
own stream of Consciousness is not there
and yet it is there it's a perturbation
on this little on this slice through you
how beautifully did you put it it's a
slice through you it may even be a slice
that controls you
I'm gonna think about that for a while
I mean I I personally uh I try to be
really good to other human beings I try
to put love out there I try to be the
exact same person in public exam and
private
but it's a set of principles I operate
under I'm I have a temper I have an ego
I have flaws
how much of it
how much have I how much of the
subconscious
am I aware how much am I existing in
this slice and how much of that is who I
am
um in in this context of AI
the thing I present to the world and to
myself in the private of my own mind
when I look in the mirror how much is
that who I am similar with AI the thing
it presents in conversation how much is
that who it is
because to me if it sounds human and it
always sounds human
it awfully starts to become something
like human
no unless there's an alien actress who
is learning how to sound human
yeah he's getting good at it boy to you
that's a fundamental difference that's a
that's a really deeply important
difference if it looks the same if it
quacks like a duck
if it does all duck-like things but it's
an alien actress underneath that's
fundamentally different
if in fact there's a whole bunch of
thought going on in there which is very
unlike human thought and is directed
around like okay what would a human do
over here
and
well first of all I think it matters
because there are there's you know like
insides are real and do not match
outsides like the inside of a like the a
brick is not like a hollow shell
containing only a surface there's an
inside of the brick if you like put it
into an x-ray machine you can see the
inside of the brick
um
and
you know you know just because we cannot
understand what's going on inside GPT
does not mean that that it is not there
a blank map does not correspond to a
blank territory
I think it is like
predictable with near certainty that if
we knew what was going on inside GPT or
let's let's say gpt3 or even like gpt2
to take one of the systems that like has
actually been open source by this point
if I recall correctly
um
like if we knew it was actually going on
there there is no doubt in my mind that
there are some things it's doing that
are not exactly what a human does if you
train a thing that is not architected
like a human to predict the next output
that anybody on the internet would make
this does not get you this agglomeration
of all the people on the internet that
that like rotates the person you're
looking for into place and then
simulates that per and then like
simulates the internal processes of that
person one to one it like it is to some
degree an alien actress it cannot
possibly just be like a bunch of
different people in there exactly like
the people but how much of it is like
learn how much of it is by gradient
descent
getting optimized to perform similar
thoughts as humans think in order to
predict human outputs versus being
optimized to carefully consider how to
play a role how to like how humans work
predict the the actress the predictor
that in a different way than humans do
well you know that's the kind of
question that with like 30 years of work
by half the planet's physicists we can
maybe start to answer you think so I
think that's that difficult so to get to
I think you just gave it as an example
that a strong AGI could be
fundamentally different from a weak AGI
because there now could be an alien
actress in there that's manipulating
well there's a difference so I think
like even gp22 probably has like a like
very stupid fragments of alien actress
in it there's there's a difference
between like the notion that the actress
is somehow manipulative like for example
gpt3 I'm guessing
to whatever extent there's an alien
actress in there versus like something
that that mistakenly believes it's a
human yes or well not well you know
maybe not even being a person
um
so like the the question of like
like prediction via alien actress
cogitating versus prediction via being
isomorphic to the thing predicted is a
spectrum
and
even it's what and to whatever extent
this is the alien actress I'm not sure
that there's like a whole person alien
actress with like different goals
from predicting the next step being
manipulative or anything like that yeah
that might be gpt5 or gpt6 even but
that's the strong AGI you're concerned
about as an example you're providing why
we can't do research on AI alignment
effectively on gpt4 that would apply to
gpt6 it's it's one of a bunch of things
that change at different points
I'm trying to get out ahead of the curve
here but you know if you imagine what
the textbook from the future would say
if we'd actually been able to study this
for 50 years without killing ourselves
and without transcending and you like
just imagine like a wormhole opens and a
textbook from that impossible World
falls out yes the textbook is not going
to say there is a single sharp threshold
where everything changes it's going to
be like of course we know that like best
practices for aligning these systems
must like take into account the
following like seven major thresholds of
importance which are passed at the
following suffer in different points
yeah is what the textbook is going to
say
I asked this question of Sam Allman
which if GPT is the thing that unlocks
AGI which version of GPT will be in the
textbooks as the fundamental leap and he
said a similar thing that it just seems
to be a very linear thing I don't think
anyone it we won't know for a long time
what was the big leap the textbook isn't
going to think it isn't going to talk
about big leaps because big leaps are
the way you think when you have like a
very simple model of a very simple
scientific model of what's going on
where it's just like all this stuff is
there or all the stuff is not there
or like there's a single quantity and
it's like increasing linearly it's like
the textbook would say like well and
then gpt3 had like capability w x y and
and gpt4 had like capability Z1 Z2 and
Z3
like not in terms of what it can
externally do but in terms of like
internal Machinery that started to be
present
it's just because we have no idea of
what the internal Machinery is that we
are not already seeing like chunks of
Machinery appearing piece by piece as
they no doubt have been we just don't
know what they are
but don't you think there could be
whether you put in the category of
Einstein
with Theory relativity so very concrete
models of reality that are considered to
be giant leaps in our understanding or
or someone like Sigmund Freud or more
kind of mushy
theories of the human mind don't you
think we'll have big potentially big
leaps and understanding of that kind in
Into the Depths of these systems
sure but like humans having great leaps
in their map their understanding of the
system is a very different concept from
the system itself acquiring new chunks
of machinery
so the rate at which it acquires that
Machinery might uh accelerate faster
than our understanding
oh it's been like vastly exceeding the
yeah the right to which it's getting
capabilities is vastly over racing our
ability to understand what's going on in
there